it certainly looks like that doesn't it
i mean why would mr javid write in this
way if he didn't think it was serious
unless he you assume he's it's some kind
of scam to
show him in a good light i think he's
genuine uh i think it was very dangerous
i think he said the right thing and i
hope that uh john whittingdale he's
pretty wise in these areas will have
exactly the same view well could it work
though because many people are annoyed
when they see
people supporting dreadful acts of
terrorism appearing on the airwaves
they do and i can understand the
frustration of the home office and
others and indeed ordinary citizens like
ourselves um getting irritated by this
but does anyone seriously think that
people are being radicalized and going
off to syria and where else because
people like chowdhury are being
interviewed on sky news or news night i
don't think so that's not how it happens
it happens online now it happens in
sermons in certain mosques or wherever
uh that's that seems to be the way it
goes one to one much more likely and
frankly i don't can't see anywhere at
all in which this was going to help any
kind of government because even if you
were to use it
it almost certainly would go off in a
huge bang in your face a great row about
censorship in the media is what what
kind of good does that do to anyone so i
think it was wrong thinking we did have
a period of course during the troubles
in northern ireland where there was
uh attempts to
censor
certainly the live voices of leading
republican figures and other
parliamentary figures uh what was the
effect of that in your view well i think
in the end it was discredited the the
broadcasters of all parties found a way
around it by sort of putting the words
up in other ways uh and
i think the public thought it's a bit
rum
you don't have to agree with people's
views to want to hear them and frankly
hear them properly interrogated by the
likes of you and uh evan davis and
others that's really what we we need to
understand and
push and get to the bottom of that's
what the public need i think so what is
the responsibility of
national broadcasters in terms of
interviewing people who are supporting
terrorism or indeed other uh very
unattractive acts
hey you can't put on people inciting
terrorism or breaking the law that that
that that's as it is now and i think is
as it should be but uh otherwise i think
you've got to do it in a reasonably
thoughtful way every now and then you've
got to find out what do these people
think and why do they think it and let's
really interrogate them in front of the
public you can't you don't if you're
doing that every night of the week
you're doing something seriously wrong
if you're doing it
in in a in a soft and feeble way you're
doing something seriously wrong but if
you're not doing it at all i think
you're letting down the public
and does the existence of the internet
the fact that a channel can be banned
from broadcasting and then go on the
internet does this really mean that uh
frankly it's a pretty uh fruitless
battle as far as the politicians are
concerned
well i think it's hard for them i i one
can understand that but that doesn't
make it right to
start censoring
television news in any kind of way or
documentaries the internet is something
else all together as as we
as we know unless you do what they do in
china or i see now is happening in
russia and start to interfere with with
that i think
that's not a way for a free society to
go is it that's why thank you very much